everybody this jeff posnick from the
youtube developer relations team and
we're continuing a series of videos
talking about the migration that
developers might have from going from
version 2 of the YouTube data API to
version 3 we strongly encourage all
developers to start that migration if
they haven't done so yet and today we're
gonna be talking about a way of
subscribing to a user's channel and show
how that's changed between version 2 and
version 3 of the API so let's first talk
a little bit about how you would
subscribe to a given YouTube channel in
version 2 of the API and I just have a
page in the documentation up here to
just give an overview for folks who
aren't familiar this is the actual
restful api call that you would use in
version 2 you know everything again is
adam xml-based so you have this pretty
big XML document that you would pass in
in a post request that's been
authenticated obviously and you know
this will end up subscribing to a given
channel so you know that does work but
let's talk about how you would do that
in the more modern version 3 of the
YouTube data API so to start in version
3 we operate on channel IDs rather than
legacy usernames and this is
particularly important because there are
not a legacy usernames for every given
YouTube channel there are channels out
there that just have channel IDs
associated with them so using a channel
ID consistently throughout version 3 of
the API means you could deal the exact
same way with any type of channel even
these newer channels that don't have
legacy usernames but that also means
that if we do have a channel and we know
that what the legacy username is we need
to first translate that legacy username
into a channel ID so let's do that using
the v3 API call YouTube channels that
list I'm going to show an example of
making this API call from within the API
Explorer which is just a web-based
harness for making API calls
and just kind of simplifies things it's
a great way to play around with the API
before you actually start writing code
using our client libraries if you wanted
to just experiment with what different
API parameters do really highly
encourage that you check it out so in
this particular case we want to
translate a user name into a channel ID
so in v3 there's this concept of a part
parameter that most of our operations
take and I'm gonna say in this
particular case I want the ID part
returned think of this as a way of kind
of limiting the response that you get
back from the API so that it only in
contains information that you
specifically asked for instead of
receiving you know really large document
that has all the details about a channel
I'm saying here all I want back is the
ID ID so this is going to result in fast
response it's great for you know
contexts where you might have limited
bandwidth or you know just not don't
want to deal with processing a whole big
response document so I'm gonna say I
want the ID and the channel that I want
the ID for is Google developers kind of
our standard subscription channel and
I'm gonna go down here and I'm going to
click execute this is making the v3 API
call for me and I'm gonna get back this
very small response and Jason and it
contains this ID value so let me copy
that and I'm going to use it in my next
API call and the actual way of inserting
a subscription in V through the API is
with a YouTube dot subscriptions that
insert call I have here the
documentation for that particular API
call if you haven't looked through the
v3 API documentation yet I'd recommend
that you pour through it a little bit it
looks a little daunting and that there's
a whole bunch of different kind of
methods listed over here on the left
hand side that you navigate through but
I think you'll find that all of the
methods follow very very consistent
interface and naming conventions that
are used throughout and once you kind of
get familiar with making API calls
against one particular service using
methods and other services should come
become second nature so hopefully you'll
find it's a really consistent API so
again in this particular case I have the
documentation for the subscriptions
insert method open and you'll learn a
little bit more about what the different
parameters are and you'll learn about
what you could set in the request body
when you're making your YouTube API v3
request in this particular case it's
saying that I need to specify something
for snippet dot resource ID and one of
the other nice things about the v3
documentation is that we have these
alive snippets of code that demonstrate
how to make the API call using the
client library selected over here so you
know Java PHP Python Ruby for this
particular API call so if you were doing
Python code for instance you could
pretty much just copy this and do it
straight away without having to change
too much but I want to show how you can
make that API call a little bit more of
an agnostic way so we have pretty much
the equivalent of this other page this
API Explorer embedded inline in our
documentation at the very bottom of this
page and it's going to allow me to make
this API call and the other nice thing
that allows me to do is go through the
OAuth 2 flow for authorizing access to
my particular channel it has to know you
know who I am before I'll let me
subscribe to a given channel so this
simplifies things for testing purposes
I'm just going to click authorize down
here when you're writing your own code
you're going to want to you know make
use of your own o auth to registration
and we have some other training material
out there that kind of talks to you
through the whole process of getting up
to speed with OAuth 2 but for these
purposes we could just test using that
and I'm going to put in part equals
snippet because I know from reading up
here that I need to set a value for
snippet resource ID so
is kind of my way for an instant even
though this is doing an insert call it's
saying what fields I'm gonna be setting
in the request body and this API
Explorer has a really nice interface
over here for just choosing what I am
setting in the request body it's a way
of kind of like programmatically
building up my request body for me again
if you're writing real code you're gonna
be probably using a client library
there's gonna be equivalents of doing
this in each client library and refer to
our documentation
you could also refer to github.com
/youtube where we have all these
document all these examples that are
inline in the docs you know we have kind
of a standalone version there so check
that out but for illustrative purposes
I'm going to just do this over here so
I'm setting snippet resource ID channel
ID and I'm going to be pasting in the
channel ID that I got from the previous
call and I'm gonna click execute at this
point I will have a subscription to that
channel so that's great
it just gives me some information about
the channel I they just subscribe to
over here in the response and looks like
everything worked as expected so that
gives you an example of how you could
make a YouTube data API version 3
subscription insertion I think that once
you get familiar with that basic way of
doing subscription insertions you'll
find that things like inserting a new
playlist or adding items to a playlist
or doing a number of other operations
all follow very same principle and you
know hopefully it'll be a
straightforward migration for you moving
your code from v2 to the v3 equivalent
so thanks very much for taking the time
to watch this again i'm jeff posnick
from the youtube developer relations
team and happy migrating